John Prine was beloved by his fans who
are still grieving his loss
Fiona Whelan prime says they miss her
late husband so does she
what's it been like putting this concert
together it's been difficult it's been
difficult at times but it's also being a
great distraction Prime's friends have
all come out for him Bonnie Raitt is
performing his classic angel from
Montgomery Kacey Musgraves is playing a
song she wrote in homage to prime and
Jason is Ville is singing another prime
standard hello in there
you know when you're listening to it
John Prine song it's very easy to forget
you're listening to a song at all he did
to me the ultimate trick of just making
it seem like it was magic Frei never
sought the limelight but at 73 he'd been
in the midst of a remarkable renaissance
he'd sold out Radio City Music Hall been
inducted into the Songwriters Hall of
Fame there is no better feeling in the
world than having a killer song in your
pocket and you're the only one in the
world that's heard it it's a really
great big and earned a lifetime
achievement Grammy on CBS Sunday morning
in 2018 I asked him are you enjoying
this resurgence tip 745 years to get the
job he did kind of get a victory lap
didn't he he absolutely did and John
being John as humble a man as he was the
biggest thrill was that he got to buy a
Porsche 911 which he neither he or I
could get in or out of so what did he do
with the Porsche 911 he parked it in the
garage John Prine met Fiona Whelan in
Dublin in 1988 there was an immediate
connection we were hardly the best
candidates to think about like let's go
off and make a family together you know
I was 15 years younger than John he'd
already been married twice before so why
did it work I think love
and persistence we really worked at
staying vulnerable to each other and for
each other
Fiona helped him beat cancer twice then
this past March after a European tour
both contracted the coronavirus and the
day in fact I came out of quarantine
John started displaying serious symptoms
was that when you took into the hospital
I took him to the ER I had to leave him
at the door that was one of the hardest
things I've ever done I've never I have
never not been with him through an
illness
finally on Prime's 13th day in intensive
care
you were allowed to visit him yeah I got
a call on our wedding anniversary on
April 6th and the doctor just said you
need to come now mrs. prime and I
honestly wanted to throw up and I spent
17 hours with him he was unconscious but
I talked to him I got to tell him
everything I ever wanted to tell him
Fiona stayed until the end but there are
three sons Jack Tommy and Jody did not
get the chance to say goodbye
how are the boys doing they're sad
they're sad John was proud of them if
they never got off the sofa John would
have been proud of them how are you
doing Fiona I am I mean uncharted
territory sometimes a friend will call
and ask me how I am and I'll say I was
hoping that you would tell me but I know
- I'll be okay you do yeah I have a I
have a resilience I have the resilience
muscle which is a little exhausted right
now but I'm gonna be okay John left me a
lot a lot of memories music cars
[Laughter]